first question I've got for you today is
if you had the opportunity to swap roles
with anybody else in the Star Wars film
franchise who would you pick and why oh
wow I'd swap the roles with with Jana
because she's super cool has amazing big
hair and gets to ride like all the time
you know I swap rows a channel like that
I can't wait to see more
obviously baby Yoda is the hottest thing
in the world right now and is melting
hearts everywhere and we want to help
make that happen even more so in the
lines of like baby's first if you could
witness baby Yoda's first fill in the
blank what would it be so first words
first Christmas something like that Oh
baby Yoda's first birthday that'd be so
cute how would baby yo to celebrate and
who would be at the party well see
Valdosta two birds one stone because we
be able to find out more about the you
know Yodas people so perhaps you know
he's a distant distant cousin maybe
there be you know some of the
grandparents there that will talk about
Yoda and talk about the past maybe so I
think the first birthdays definitely way
to do it and then hopefully baby Yoda's
name is written on the cake so we
finally know what to call it yeah and
it's like a swamp cake thing because
kind of eats the most disgusting and
stuff like a frog if you had a name an
unsung hero of rise of Skywalker who
would it be so we know all of you guys
but was there a PA or someone on I don't
know the stunt team that made a big
difference in your day or work super
hard uh oh I definitely say stunt
coordinator eunice she was bad ass like
for me I think she came as stepped up
the action in the Star Wars movies
because a lot of these guys are not
superheroes that have like the abilities
is or Syrian and kylo that do all the
the mad stuff but to make you know kind
of like grounded a military style to
fighting more interesting and dramatic
is a challenge and she that she done
well with her and now we have to focus
on the ensemble a little because you
have a unique situation where I think
you get to work with more of the
ensemble in all three of the movies than
anybody else and
chemistry with everybody but I am
curious did you ever jump into your
first scene with someone and just like
feel that spark say we got something
special here yeah me and Oscar me lost
got pretty much from the auditions our
first scene that we did was when Finn
and I power there in the TIE fighter and
you know he gives him Finn his name that
was the main audition scene during the
process and we nailed it like I don't
know we just said automatic chemistry
definitely tell I think that's why
everybody likes the the bromance between
the two of you I am a man of it myself
thank you what do you think that the
franchise or this last trilogy got from
the passing of the baton from JJ to Ryan
and then back to JJ that it might not
have had had it had three different
directors just one director what do you
think that combination brings out of
this final trilogy I don't know like I
just think he's each individual's time
for them to kind of have their own
creative take a space opera and I think
JJ is gonna do what he's gonna do based
on his decisions it in his individuality
in the same ways as Ryan it's two
different fields but I definitely feel
if it was good though for me to have the
consistency of one director coming back
obviously from the beginning and then
come in to tie up the loose ends and
confirm this whole whole story make
sense so this is coming to an end now
but there is no doubt that Star Wars
will still thrive on the big screen so
if you had to give any advice to someone
out there who is about to do what you
did on force awakens to really make the
most of the experience what would you
tell them just have fun have fun you
know like you know it's not that deep
have fun enjoy it and then when it's
done is done
yeah are you gonna really really miss it
so you know enjoy the moment did you get
to keep anything from it yeah definitely
actually kept I've got official gifts
this time I didn't have to steal
anything which is so it's good can you
share anything about the official gifts
yeah I got my big you know my rifle my
my sidearm the thin jacket the thin vest
like you know Disney were like you know
it's time for you to get some
memorabilia and I got some good stuff